das Ende von Öl und Gasheizungen drückt
näher das GEG das Gebäude Energiegesetz
soll den Abschied von herkömmlichen
Brennwertgeräten einläuten nach den
Plänen von Bundeswirtschaftsminister
Robert Habeck soll bereits ab Januar 24
jede neue Heizung zu 65% mit
erneuerbaren Energien betrieben werden
doch der Zeitplan wackelt innerhalb der
Berliner Regierungskoalition ist die
Stimmung aufgeheizt vor allem die FDP
sieht Klärungsbedarf Tritt auf die
Bremse der Ausgang des Streits ums
gegossen rund 41 Millionen Haushalte
gibt es in Deutschland davon heizen gut
30 Millionen mit Gas oder Öl Gisela
Messmann ist ihre alte Gasheizung los
die neue Wärmepumpe ist fast installiert
der Großteil der Anlage steht zwar nach
wie vor im Keller doch auch im Innenhof
ist die neue Heizung nicht zu übersehen
ich bin immer allem abgeschlossen ein
modernen und ja ich denke mal das macht
ist zwar nicht schöner geworden jetzt
hier im Garten aber
man kann nicht alles haben ne
Anlagentechniker Valerie Müller ist mit
seinem Kollegen gut dreieinhalb Tage mit
dem Einbau beschäftigt die Kundin
investiert rund 30.000 € in ihrem
Bungalow Baujahr 86 davon werden in
diesem Fall 35% vom Staat gefördert
die Förderung macht ihr natürlich einen
großen wir haben das im August beantragt
und ich habe im Januar dann die Zusage
gekriegt aus Berlin mit 35 Prozent ich
glaube jetzt ist das sogar wieder etwas
höher aber gut und das war das und wenn
ich dann gerechnet habe was mich eine
neue Gasheizung kostet und was
vielleicht nicht das Gas dann kostet in
Zukunft wird fossile Energie hier nicht
mehr benötigt
heizungsbauerin Sabine Heimann hat die
Anlage geplant im Keller steht das
Herzstück Technik plus Pufferspeicher
die Fachfrau ist überzeugt davon dass
die Wahl einer Wärmepumpe auch bei
diesem Haus die richtige ist dem
Standard aus den späten 80er Jahren
ausreichend Platz und Teile der alten
Anlage können hier weiter genutzt werden
wir haben hier natürlich die guten
Voraussetzungen der Fußbodenheizung das
ist natürlich immer schöner heißt aber
nicht zwangsläufig wenn Heizkörper drin
wären dass man dann keine warmen
Wärmepumpe hätte einbauen können Baujahr
86 ist von der Dämmung her schon ein
relativ guter Standard möglicherweise
hat der ein oder andere Bewohner auch
schon mal neue Fenster gemacht dann ist
es noch mal ein bisschen besser aber die
Voraussetzungen waren gut Heimat führt
einen Traditionsbetrieb Ihre Firma gibt
es schon über 50 Jahre vor den Toren
Hannovers zwei drei Stunden täglich
führt sie Kundengespräche viel Arbeit
wenig Zeit und fehlende Fachkräfte ein
möglicherweise schneller Start des GEG
setze die Handwerker zusätzlich unter
Druck und verunsichere die Kunden sagt
sie ich habe eben einen Anruf gehabt ein
alter Herr der sagt ich will noch ganz
schnell mir Ersatzteile hinlegen für
meinen 13 Jahre alten Kessel das brauche
doch gar nicht es wird einfach viel zu
wenig kommuniziert selbst wir Fach Leute
wissen nicht was tatsächlich auf uns
zukommt und es kommt einfach zu schnell
die fachbranche bemängelt neben der
Zeitplanung die schlechte Information
durch die Politik vieles sei unklar und
Führer auch dazu dass die Kunden panisch
und schnell jetzt noch eine neue
herkömmliche Heizung einbauen heißt es
so kommt es dass auch Öl und
Gasheizungen derzeit extrem nachgefragt
sind
Jürgen Engelhardt vom Fachverband
Sanitär Heizung Klima ist überzeugt
davon dass der unüberlegte Einbau
auslaufender Technik zu Frust bei den
Kunden führen wird ich bin mir ziemlich
sicher dass irgendwann die Menschen die
jetzt ein Gaskessel einbauen neu sich
darüber ärgern werden dass in der
falsche Entscheidung getroffen haben
warum ist das so weil die
Energiekosten sicherlich auch durch CO2
Bepreisung und andere Maßnahmen im Markt
hochgehen werden und dann dieses Geld
was ich in einen neuen Gas
Brennwertkessel oder ölbrennwertkessel
investiert habe besser angelegt wäre in
einer Wärmepumpe wo ist denn
funktioniert oder vielleicht sogar ein
Pelletkessel und es gibt auch noch
andere Möglichkeiten im Innenstädte in
der städtischen Bereich dann vielleicht
auch eine erwärmenetze
allerdings muss man da eben genau gucken
was es möglich und das bedarf Ruhe und
Planung und das war einer durchgeht dass
man einer guckt und die Realität ein
bisschen rein bringt
im neu gebauten ein- und zwei
Familienhaus ist die Wärmepumpe heute
Standard auch in vielen Bestandsgebäuden
dieser Größe kann eine Wärmepumpe gut
und effizientieren problematischer sehr
große schlecht gedämmte Gebäude oder
Altbauten dort kann eine Wärmepumpe dann
uneffektiv sein das Gebäude in den
kalten Monaten möglicherweise nicht mehr
richtig aufheizen gut geplant und
Betrieben durch erneuerbare Energie ist
die Wärmepumpe ein Klimaschützer spart
CO2 und wie sieht es aktuell im
laufenden Betrieb beim Geld aus das kann
man ja im Moment schlecht sagen weil die
die Energiepreise sind ja so dass dass
zwar das Gas noch teurer ist als das vor
einem Jahr noch war oder vor anderthalb
Jahren und auch das Öl
aber die Preisspirale ja deutlich wieder
runtergegangen ist
sie wird sukzessive teurer werden durch
CO2 Bepreisung und andere mag
Mechanismen aber was ich eben auch habe
der Strompreis ist ja im Moment auch
deutlich teurer oder für viele Ort
deutlich teurer und das ganze hängt
natürlich auch sehr stark am Strompreis
wenn ich mit Strom heize und habe einen
günstigen Strompreis dann werde ich
natürlich auch entsprechend ja günstiger
günstig heizen eine Luftwärmepumpe nutzt
die Wärme der Außenluft diese erwärmt
ein Kältemittel das schon bei niedrigen
Temperaturen verdampft ein Kompressor
verdichtet diesen Dampf und erwärmt ihn
so weiter der heiße Dampf erwärmt dann
das Heizwasser allerdings wird das
Heizungswasser nicht so heiß wie bei
einer Gas- oder Ölheizung zurück zu
Gisela Messmann
für die 80-Jährige ist klar dass sich
die 30.000 € Investition in naher
Zukunft nicht amortisieren wird aber es
steigert den Wert des Hauses
vielleicht wenn ich sowas mal verkaufen
muss also wie gesagt
das nicht aber ich habe wirklich dran
gedacht dann an die Umwelt und was
gemacht wird und so weiter und
kann ich jeder sagen mir bei mir nicht
morgen geht die Anlage in Betrieb dann
beginnt bei ihr die wärmewende Gisela
Messmann hofft dass noch viele
Hausbesitzer nachziehen